support for this past weekend comes from
manscaped who is the men's best in below
the belt grooming manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels you know your body is not
your own it's a rental your parents made
it and somebody made them so it's all
this is all second fifth ninth 70th
generation and so your junk at that area
you know that area is uh it needs to be
tended to now that is your
responsibility and you got to tighten it
up untrimmed pubic hair are a thing of
the past it's time to gear up and get
yourself the gift of Shaving this
holiday season I'm talking about the
manscaped perfect package 2.0 I've I've
definitely dealt my my ah my lower area
a new lease on life with manscaped and
they're there they're really it's really
a grab bag of beautiful things that they
offer here manscaped has redesigned the
electric trimmer their lawnmower 2.0 has
proprietary advanced skin safe
technology this Tim it's this uh this
trimmer won't Nick you're near nuts or
snag your sack
so sometimes Santa he comes down the
chimney and people don't know there's a
nail right there on the top of the
chimney whoo that's presents are going
into the fire if that's the case so you
got to keep that sac intact the
lawnmower 2.0 also comes inside their
perfect package which makes the perfect
gift this holiday season it's everything
you need to take care of your lineage
don't use the same trim on your face as
you're using on your balls that is just
nasty tis the season to manscape so get
yourself your dad your bro
they're your friends even uh someone you
don't even know but someone you just
imagine has that real that harried yard
get them the manscaped perfect package
2.0 get 20% off and free shipping with
the code Theo
th EO at manscape comm that's right get
20% off and free shipping with the code
theo at manscaped dot-com that's 20% off
and free shipping at manscape comm use
code theo clean up your nuts and make
Santa proud this year what's up you
little yard VARs we we we we we move in
have you washed your hands today I was
just wondering that if everybody is
washing their hands that used to be a
real thing yet to wash your hands
because it was a lot more social
interaction was based on that shake you
know so you had to go hands first into
the future and if you washed your hands
I'm asking you just you know answer to
yourselves but or you what are you doing
you just ride and dirty
you got those phalanges of the Ganges
huh you got dirt on your mitts you just
rolling dirty mitt first into the future
come home we're better than that unless
you go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
another man's ocean
wrote to a paper ecology
you know it's bishop gone here
[Music]
you can have
and that's the point right there when
they say anything you won't that I would
take my top off if I had a top and
that's one of the gifts of women they
have the different layers that they can
tempt you they got the scarf they got
the vest they got the blouse they got
the UM bra
it's just wonder than em finally like
all right
you know here's my money and that's one
thing that women have that that layered
they they can really they have that the
different layers of temptation but when
they say anything you won't that's when
I would take my bra off and look I'll
tell you this if I was front row at a
bishop gun show I might wear a damn bra
and I might unhook that little that
little titty cape and just throw it onto
the stage because that sounds freeing
that sounds very very freeing that is
anything you want by Bishop gun thank
you for being here today it is December
2nd Monday December 2nd in the year 2019
in time that's where we are and I hope
you're doing at least decent or better
and then sometime I even hope that
you're doing great I just got back from
Louisiana and I ate it people say right
when they you know right when you get
back out of Louisiana people want to
smell your breath
they wanna you know they want to check
you you know like certain places you go
people want to check you for different
food and different items you know you go
to New Mexico somebody will friskier for
a couple of uh geodes or you go to UM
you know you go to Wisconsin somebody
will run that cheese check on you you
know they'll they'll uh they'll freaking
they'll diddle your chimichanga for a
little bit of cheddar you feel me people
want to they want to check you in
Louisiana you know you go down there and
the food is just now it's like you put
it in your mouth and it some of it is
still alive the crab the the oyster and
it'll just some of it I had a crab it
was so fresh the thing climb down my
damn throat just speelunk right into my
own stomach it wasn't even a meal that's
a damn pet
I feel like an aquarium and they have
that there they have everything you know
I eat at all this always to dress and
stuffed you know stuff oyster grilled
oyster Grill crab you know Gator bites
they had a urban gentleman selling Gator
bites on the side of the road out of the
back of a truck by the box it was just
in like a little cardboard kind of setup
and you get 20 Gator bites right there
from that man I said dad and it would
then look that Gator I don't know how
fresh it was or fresh it wasn't but it
could I mean that thing it bit back
I had it probably about 11 of those
nuggets while I was driving across the
Atchafalaya Basin and about nine of
those [ __ ] they bit right back I'm
happy to be back here I'm happy to be
here with you I hope you're doing well
today what's going on um yeah had a nice
weekend went through the old
neighborhood I went for a jog and
there's something up it's like you're
almost running through your past when
you do that you know I get out there and
and a lot of it's a little sad it's you
know I'm kind of a nostalgia jockey if
you cut my arms off you know I wouldn't
have any arms but I would love nostalgia
I love just time warping and just going
back inside of myself and then you know
through the filing cabinets of my
insides and and pulling out old files
and and looking at old memories and when
you jog through the old neighborhood you
get that you know you get that I had a
squirrel
this one squirrel ran right alongside me
I mean he might have been maybe like a
grandchild of a squirrel that I grew up
with or something but I mean this thing
ran probably about a mile and a quarter
with me and that's I don't know maybe he
was looking for help I don't know what
the hell he was doing but I've never
seen that in my life and I didn't have
any streets on me you know I didn't have
any little you know uh-oh
at corns or you know no squirrel treats
on me and this thing this little critter
just zipping and I mean damn like he had
GPS or something like he had a damn my
iPhone I mean he was just making all the
turns with me it was really wild but it
made me feel a little bit at home just
uh just having that animal I guess kind
of just joined me on my job but yeah you
pass old house he's like oh man I you
know I really you know I used to go over
there and sometime that lady would give
me a you know a bowl of Doritos or
something an afternoon you know we had
this lady boss Miss green and if I came
over there real sweaty she would give me
a bowl
and I don't know why and it didn't
matter you know but if I came over there
dry but I wouldn't get nothing and so I
started just knowing I had to go over
there sweat hell sometime I pour half a
glass of water on my face and just
[ __ ] my way over there to those
snacks but yeah just going through the
old neighborhood by all I remember I
know I got a little uh I got a little
sex over there by that house you know oh
I remember
dude one house right down the street
from me
I don't almost lost my virginity in this
homestead and they had a the girl's
mother came in the room and I didn't
know what to do and so I walked right
over and introduced myself
dude I was I mean I was I was buried you
know it's five-legged at that point if
you get me I was a five legged animal
when I met that woman and um man it was
just embarrassing and I also remember
her her daughter kind of smelled like
cigarettes I remember that a little bit
and uh but but yeah you go through the
neighborhood and you just all of that
happens like aw man my friend drove his
truck into that house right there on ha
you know when he was on high on liquor
and everything and like damn that's
crazy you know you're like oh that house
burned down oh that person passed away
that guy died from a but you know he was
in a boating incident they call it when
you die in a boat but all of that
happens when you're in an old
neighborhood and so it was you know that
was pretty enjoyable um what else did I
get into
oh I was in New Orleans went to the
Saints game went to the Saints game
Saints and the Panthers took my nephew's
I was beautiful these little beautiful
bastards watching them just just take it
all in and the Superdome has changed
when I went there was you know there was
uh there wasn't as much you know hoopla
there weren't as many lights and laser
beams and you know it'll shoot every now
and then they'll shoot some [ __ ] out of
a cannon and she'll fly across the dome
now it's crazy you know they got when I
was going when I first started going it
was it they didn't have as much you know
hoopla and so it was just more simple
and was just damn you know you see but
now they got people in the stands
peoples you know everybody's you know
everybody's got you know all kind of
face pain and a big whistle on their
head and somebody's wearing like
somebody had on like like a whole suit
made out of Flags like the yellow NFL
Flags pretty cool and watching it just
watching those children just take it in
it was really you know it was special my
brother in our first game we went to the
you know my mother was dating a man and
this man was a was a Jewish gentleman
and urban gentleman too and so he was
doubled out and she and he gave us
tickets to a game and we went and as
we're walking up to the game it was I
don't know when it was man that was
Saints versus the Bears somebody offered
to buy our tickets so we're like oh hell
yeah we'll sell we'll sell them they
said $35 for a ticket and my brother and
I were so excited about going to the
game the game we're going to the super
down we were excited man he was alright
he ripped one of my damn my eyebrows off
that's how excited he was you know and I
wasn't even mad at him because I just I
love the Saints so much
and so we were going to the dome and mom
dropped us off for hell she might have
made us walk there I don't remember but
we got there and we had our ticket boy
and I'm I was so nervous and my hands
was just sweating and my ticket was I
had my ticket was wet that's how excited
I was I just had that excitement water
just climbing out of my pores and we got
to the dome and it was huge man it
looked like like heaven had just put a
little nipple down here on the world and
we got over an air and writers were
walking up this man said I'll give you I
think it was a man it could have been at
the time a lesbian but this man or a
strong woman said I'll give you $35 for
the ticket and we're lying $35 what do
we never seen the Saints but we never
seen $35 so we said we agreed you know
I'm saying do-don do-don three $5
anything I'll buy you know I'll buy the
Saints you know what I'm saying I'll
paint my brother black and gold and just
throw the ball at him in the street I'll
do it we'll figure something out cuz
total that was gonna be $70 and we were
good at being poor and we were good at
math and and we agreed and then they
said that they were undercover police
and it's illegal to sell your tickets
and we said well we didn't want to sell
them you wanted a Buy and and I remember
we got into an argument with these
people or you know these officers or
whatever discussion I mean I'm sure we
weren't really arguing but then they
took us up to the cop suite or whatever
and let us eat all everything they had
dude they had so many corn dogs gravy
soda
dude I probably had I had six corn dogs
man
dude I was mostly corn I don't even know
if I saw the game
but I saw all four quarters of my
stomach in that bit and that thing was
you know I was just I could feel
overtime just in my gut but I was really
god it was it was awesome man but we
took that we took the nephews and that
was good what else we oh I met the best
crossdresser name ever I met a woman
named turducken and this young lady or
middle-aged or older woman she was a
crossdresser or transvestite I'm not
sure not trying to be offensive I don't
know and most people don't know you
don't know but her name was turducken
and if you don't know that's a duck
stuffed in a turkey stuffed in a chicken
and if that ain't the most I mean if
that isn't the the pinnacle of Louisiana
transvestite names then I don't know
nothing she had huge earlobes also uh
you know we had a lot of amazing calls
this time a lot of really there's always
great ones and but I really felt
connected to a lot of the calls that
have come in and thank you for anyone
that's hit the hotline let's get a call
right here as to who listens to this
show hey Theo
it's the Matt my other buddy Matt yo-yo
just calling to say you know we love the
show whoa - Matt's to Matt's that now
that's always I mean if you have a
friend that's the same name as you
that's is that egotistical you know
imagine your name's Clarence and you got
seven other people named Clarence and
those are your buddies and at one point
I'd look as I'd look at a couple of
those Clarence's and be like dang bro
you guys are a little self-motivated
here double Matt we got double Matt's
right here let's hear more when got
stories of our past weekend here we're
driving his dog from chi-town all the
way to Seattle
oh right on y'all run an animal bra
respect and I don't know if you heard
but there was a blizzard so we're trying
to drive through on the highway and
highway gets closed so we think you know
we're smarter than that we can drive up
the side roads and end up in the
Badlands which should have been a hint
but ended up getting stuck in a
snowdrift call around print get the car
out that nobody could come for help
Danis do this if you are feed this
thing's starting to sound a little
romantic huh
let's go more we're talking about each
other like this maybe yet man this could
be the end the end of each other's
bodies huh
onward long story short the fire
department shows up the local rancher
shows up we show up a lot more men sound
like a lot more men just showed up on
work they just bailed us out man it was
free Street special we ended up getting
drunk with the rancher at his place
thank all this whiskey with him couple
neighbors came by we played cards all
night oh man I gotta pull the plug dude
I'm trying to stay straight brother I
got to pull the plug on that but uh
double Matt's thank you guys for
listening man be careful out there if
you're running animals across state
lines first of all that could be a
legality issue and if it's not I can't
believe it's not because they'll pop you
for running an orange bra do you drive
an orange from New York to Hawaii
you're [ __ ] bro nope I don't [ __ ]
tase you dude you know they'll tase you
right outside of Salinas bro people
aren't playing the national produce
Association or whatever those people
agriculture mmm boy they're not playing
they'll pop a young fella for running
fruits so whatever you guys are doing
over there
you know don't I mean don't get the dog
involved in it if you guys want to be a
couple men sneaking off and getting do
that story well thank you for calling
man that's all I'm saying is thank you
for calling and whatever you guys choose
to do man I love you guys bro
and I won't be that third Matt but you
know I'll officiate the wedding dude and
uh gang bro
let's take another call on nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
is the hotline onward hey Co this is a
nurse from Salt Lake City a tenor thank
you for calling and Tanner is also a
goal of a lot of people onward um
I just got a problem but I was hoping
you could help me with um
so I'm on some antidepressants and
basically in my junk doesn't work like I
can get in bed and go but I mean I just
keep going like I never finished up and
oh wow so you really you just out there
just oh you got a book just keep bumping
homeward I know that you talked about
how you're on the same kind of
medication sometimes so I was wondering
if you have the same problems and was
wondering what you do to combat that
well combat it sounds real aggressive
you know if I dress up in a damn Navy
SEAL uniform and sneak up on my wiener
then that ain't gonna help anybody but
what I do think Brooke is yeah dude I've
taken in and oppressing so long I don't
even know what it's like to not take
them I don't know who you know I've
tried to not take them and it's hard but
how does it affect the the the body the
penis yeah I remember definitely a time
you know when I first started taking
them that I couldn't you know ejack you
know and at the time I was I was upset
about because I wanted to freakin watch
that water you feel me as sinful as it
is brother I wanted to watch that water
and now bruh I think it's great bro if
you don't ejaculate good for you dude
go to the gym tight you know what I'm
saying you you're not gonna be all tired
out
so you still you still get to do sex and
you don't get tired
go do something build a pyramid you know
I'm Sam freakin knit a hat brother live
your life do dice do something you can
be somebody if you're not you know cuz
once you bust out and you throw that Chi
you done once you spring Chi bruh that's
it
your Energy's zaft you don't know who
you are you couldn't pick yourself out
of a police lineup you its quavo bro you
done bruh
so I think you got to just be grateful
that you can't eject homework anyways I
mean help would be great I appreciate
you man have a good one yeah brother I
think you're on the right path
busting busting you know busting that
sauce that's old-school that's it that's
90's that's 2000s dude that's something
you your uncle did bro saving that
freaking saving that that potion so you
could damn freaking you know you could
be that dude if you save up all of that
gumption bruh that's what you gotta have
you save up that gumption you'll be able
to [ __ ] tie a knot with your eyes bro
man the stuff you the power you have by
holding on to that frickin body sauce
and not just blasting that stuff out
another world man just otherwise you
throwing all that you throw you spouting
otherwise you've given away that risk
water that's your Chi brother that's
your DNA and you just squirrel in and
out for some broad or some fellow you
met in the afternoon somewhere I think
you're you're better than that so I say
you just hold on do something go make a
[ __ ] tall sandwich boy go build a
pyramid you know what I'm saying you got
so much probably gumption in you if you
hold on to it you probably rearrange
your damn toes bucko
but you can do something so you know
people wondering why you know their kid
is weak and her kid is this cuz you
busted two thousand before you made your
child
imagine if you'd hold it up I just held
on just held the line and just you had
that one just so there was at least
something left in it there was at least
some decent oils in the tank by the time
a lot of us are making children these
kids but there's nothing there's nothing
in there you know there's not even any
there's probably hardly any of our DNA
in there it probably more tears and
stuff these days Helmont inves my nuts
are probably half filled with them tears
bruh but you know me but look I'm just
saying that just look at it as a
superpower and try not to just focus on
it too much imagine that Dodie you don't
want to be all you know boxers don't
blow before they fight mountain climbers
that one boy who climbed the mountain
Hope Solo you see the documentary dude
he went he went he told his girlfriend
and she was beautiful too he said look
nobody's getting their rocks off till I
get off that rock and he held the line
so I think you have a gift man I don't
think you have an affliction uh I'll
tell you this speaking of meat and how
to treat it
what's your favorite cut of meat you
like a brisket you like a back strap you
like a fillet you like something off a
fish that's just water cattle baby
that's all fish is how do you like to
prepare it you grill it you braise it up
you cook it in the Sun on the back of a
Chevelle how do you cook your meat well
I just know that when it comes to meat
quality matters and there's more than
just texture and taste I'm talking about
quality meat and I'm talking about
butcher box support the podcast
your box every month butcher box ships a
curated selection of high quality meat
right to your house I'm not talking no
tane you know something like this or
some dirty jerky I'm talking about real
high quality meat all their meat is free
of antibiotics and added hormones you're
not gonna find you know a bunch of you
know quaaludes in the meat or you know
your meat have lipstick on it none of
that bs patented straight meat it's
packed fresh and it's shipped frozen and
vacuum sealed so it stays that way
you can customize your box or go with
one of theirs it's the best meat shipped
right to your door which means one less
trip to the grocery and look I've gotten
butcher box and it's great if I'm really
like I want to make myself something I
want to get a little bit of a little bit
of animal blood in me or something I
crack open the freezer and I got a stack
of meat meat fish salmon everything it's
the best [ __ ] meat it's the best meat
shipped right to your door and right now
you can get two pounds of ground beef
and two packs of bacon absolutely free
plus $20 off your first box now that's a
deal just go to butcher box.com
Theo or use promo code Theo
at checkout that's butcher box.com slash
Theo or use promo code Theo at checkout
butcher box it's the way that meat
should be I'm gonna let you know about
this Ridge wallet and if you want to get
somebody meat that's a great gift get
them that monthly subscription they get
constant meat and if you want to get
that Ridge wallet that constant meat boy
and dude that'd be a great name for a
porn star wouldn't it constant meat
verse turducken and they just go and
just fighting in the street constant
beat Birds turducken I love watching
that fight I'm gonna say this that the
ridge wallet helps you carry what you
need every day
I used a Ridge this weekend I used it
this week and I used it last month and I
used it up very often the ridge is
bulletproof now I wouldn't ask somebody
to shoot you but if they do you have a
chance from streamlining how you carry
cash and cards in their flagship wallet
to their portable charging commuter
backpack Ridge wants you to make the
most out of whatever you're bringing
with you the best thing I like about my
Ridge is that I don't have to have that
lump in my butt a lot of senior citizens
if they have a grater or if they have a
bone you might have an uncle or
grandfather have a big bone spur on his
ass on his ass bone and he sits on the
site you know always looks like he's hot
and you know like he's hiding a couple
you know like he's hiding um maybe uh
about six pairs of mittens on one of his
ass cheeks you don't have to look like
that and you don't have to be like that
and the ridge wallet it's right there in
the front boom it's nice looking I like
that I can set it next to my phone next
to my keys and I'm keen and I'm GIDA
I'm actually gonna send one of my friend
Corey Huff he just had a baby and they
um and he lives in Illinois and I'm
gonna send him one as a gift it's free
shipping so you can get it fast and free
returns case you don't like it you don't
like it take it back and there's a
lifetime guarantee on it there's thirty
thousand five-star reviews so they've
got a lot to be confident about over at
Ridge see exactly how it works by going
to Ridge comm slash Theo
that's Ridge comm slash th EO and use
code th EO for 10% off that's right 10%
off
Ridge get that hitter get that hitter
baby a lot of great calls have come in I
want to also let you know about some
dates
the Lafayette date has sold out that's
December 26 and I'm so excited
you know I'm so grateful man I've been
working really hard recently I'm just uh
just trying to go easier on myself and
just feel a little bit better and I can
just feel it I can just start to feel it
you know and it just makes my shows
better it just you know I'm you know I
don't want to just you know I want to
feel good and so that's what so I'm
really excited I'm just it just makes me
so much more excited about how the dates
what else got Denver coming up comedy
works south and those tickets are on
sale and I don't know if that's going to
be dark arts or just kind of working on
new material Toronto will go on sale
this week
finally I promise it's going on sale
this week outside of that we have every
date in Europe is sold out for January
and I can't believe it
I can't believe I'm going to Europe not
my up Europe I'm like a pilgrim I'm
going back we're doing it again
so just I mean you know just a lot to be
thankful for right now a lot to be
thankful for and those are some of those
things what else any other dates that
might be it for now unless if you see
one online and it's and it's selling
then it's a date that I'm doing so we do
have Oxon Hill Maryland and Red Bank New
Jersey those dates are also those are in
February so thank you guys tickets
available at Theo von comm slash tour
and also at Theo von store.com a lot of
new merch we got the gang gang hit her
from with the cartoon boy on it and then
we got to get that hitter sweatshirt and
in the Rat King t-shirt and a man that
rack King t-shirts dope I wore it
yesterday just around the house so a lot
of good calls have come in and and I
feel bad I can't use them all
on here I think we probably have about
10,000 calls that have come in but but
thank you so much for anyone who's ever
submitted one and uh and for sharing
your life with uh with me and with all
of us let's take a couple calls here hey
Theo wassup this is Heather and I'm
calling to ask you how I can get my
husband to quit farting around me oh you
got that farty man you got that farty
man
Thank You Heather let's hear more from
young lady most mostly in the bed
because I'm trying to sleep the most
sleep Haven and uh crop-dusting me under
the cover so how can I get him to stop
farting everywhere I go oh man well look
I mean there's two ways you can look at
it differently if you want
yeah he's farting you know that man's
got air coming out of his butt but if
you want that could be a little sound of
love you know some animals pass gas on
each other the Japanese do it you go to
Japan do you fart somewhere I'll have to
people will come over and they'll you
know I'm saying to hug you it's all so
different places it's a different thing
so every time he does it maybe you give
him a little big wet kiss you know maybe
you tickle him when he does it you need
to have a little cute thing of your own
because some cultures yeah you pass gas
on somebody that's that's like two
months of dating in one little and one
fell poof so if he's throwing that body
smoke on you I think you just you got to
come back at him but yeah I think don't
look at it as maybe something dirty look
at it as something real beautiful
because he could fart on anybody think
about that he could pass gas on anyone
he wants but he chooses he chooses to
pass gas on you and there's you know
we're really evolved now in today's
times where everybody's got you know you
know DVD players and [ __ ] lasers and
everything but one strong storm and
people will be farting on each other for
warmth I'm saying one big flood and the
most gaseous dude in the world's gonna
have all the [ __ ] cuz that I mean
look that's it that's free heat you know
when I was growing up about a bus stop
my brother sometime a fart on my hands
sometimes if I did if I didn't have an
admittance with me so but now you could
feed him cleaner stuff and so he don't
have any scent and you're just getting
the warmth let's hear more he farted on
me in the shower the other night can you
oh you believe it anyway how do I get
him to stop farting I mean you could ask
him that's one way to get to get him to
do it you could leave him a little note
or you could just embrace him or you
could punch his ass every time he does
it you know what I'm saying you know
what you could also do lick your
freaking fingers and slap him in the
neck and I know that's violent of me to
say but dude if somebody when I was
young somebody would lick two of their
fingers and hit you in the neck as hard
as they could and whatever you were
doing you didn't do it anymore
hmm I wouldn't do anything after that
I mean I'd do nothing but good luck out
there with your man thank you for
calling
all right let's get a patreon question
that came in here
Melissa Henry wants to know do you have
a favorite Christmas show movie or
cartoon I'm curious I want to see that
new Klauss movie that I saw a billboard
for and also I like to watch home alone
the first one and I like to watch elf so
that's kind of where I'm at right now
and I'll also watch um
Little House on the Prairie Christmas
Spectacular they have like a Christmas
episode at least one that's pretty good
so I'll tune into some stuff like that I
think that's about it oh here's one
Dalton Windham asked what do you think
about comedians censoring the opinions
of fans on social media Pete Davidson
reportedly now requires a person to sign
a nondisclosure agreement to attend a
stand-up show you have to agree not to
give interviews opinions or critiques
about the show if you violate the
agreement you owe a million dollars well
first part of the question what do you
think about comedians censoring the
opinions of fans on social media I think
social media censors people all the time
if you go on you know Twitter a lot of
things are not allowed to be said on
there or if they if there's certain
things trending they'll make them not
trend so I think that's our biggest
that's the biggest censorship I'm
worried about is censoring by companies
that own the platforms we communicate on
I mean imagine if 2,000 people if we
didn't have you know social media then
we would have our voice that was our
original social media and imagine if
2,000 people are talking would you only
like to hear what 1300 of them have to
say or what 700 of them have to say then
you could mute those other ones
then that's that's Twitter and Facebook
a lot of these companies they can do
that they can say oh this we don't like
this we don't like these points of view
we can mute that that's very scary
specifically repeat Davison I saw this I
saw this that he was having people sign
an NDA and I had a couple thoughts one
part what part of me thought it was a
good idea at first I was like oh well it
makes it a safe space to speak in
because people would be afraid to talk
or people would be afraid to like
condemn you and you could get back to
just trying to be humorous so that was
my first thought it was like oh this is
interesting because if everybody signed
an NDA and you didn't have to worry
about somebody calling you out if you
tried a joke then you you be at peace to
really feel the energy that I think
people used to feel to be able to be
creative you know I don't know if
creativity has the legs that it used to
have because it's just been cut off at
the knees by so many just by so many
opinions you know
creativity has to filter through
opinions and you have to filter it
through opinions before you can even
share before you can even be creative so
that's kind of spooky and my second
thought was just wondering if uh if
Peters having a tough time at his shows
you know is he just you know I know
there's been articles about you know
issues he was having it was at least two
articles that I saw where he was having
issues now who knows if those articles
are you know how factual they are are
people being thrown out of his shows you
know I don't know sometimes I worry
about him but that could just be you
know should I worry about everything so
but that's really my thoughts on it
because these days a lot of people also
who are throwing out critiques and stuff
like that are just doing it for their
own clout so you'll have somebody to go
see somebody show this show will be fine
and then somebody will write a scathing
article just because that's gonna get
more play you know if you write
something like great about Dave
Chappelle special that's great
Dave will be happy a lot of people will
agree with you you write something
that's scathing or accused one of his
statements of being a certain anti this
or something that or then that becomes a
thing online and now your cloud is
building as a interviewer as a you know
an opinion astoria list whatever that
word means these days so I think if
there's a way for performers to limit
that then maybe that's maybe that's
maybe there's value there
maybe it'll gifts get everybody back to
a place where it's like you know I came
here to have fun and not to
just try to get something out of this
performance for myself I don't think a
lot of audience members are doing that
I've never felt like that from an
audience person or from anybody that
I've ever met at my shows but you know I
don't know I run in different circles
than mr. Pete Davidson all right let's
take a call right here on word hey
what's up deal this is Pedro I'm calling
you from probably one of the top ten
dark guard cities of the world
Chicago Oh what's up Pedro thanks for
calling man Chicago yet as Illinois and
my mother was born in Illinois and I
love that state man and I'm grateful
that it gave me her and um and thank you
for calling home word I just wanted to
call you and say that uh thank you for
uh for all that you do for other
positivity that you put out in the world
you know
you really uh you helped steer my
negativity into a more positive light
thanks man
that's nice you to say that I appreciate
uh I appreciate you saying that that's a
very sweet of you
onward especially recently I just had a
little bad breakup with a girl that has
known for quite a while and uh the
reason for the break-up was a all that
negativity that uh that I better carry
with me you know and I kind of pushed me
you know and a more a more positive path
to be in a more positive path you know I
it's it's something that I really need
to work on myself you know for this this
upcoming uh that's a coming week I'll be
taking the trip up to a New Orleans you
know because what better way to better
the dark arts and to go to a city known
for dark arts amen brother yes yeah have
fun down there in New Orleans man I hope
you have a good time and I'm sorry to
hear about that breakup and
yeah man at negativity man I feel you
yeah you know I can I can relate to that
you know I was in a relationship one
time and I was negative man you know
what a lot of the relationships I've
been in extra and I think about it I was
negative you know I didn't want to have
fun sometimes I didn't I didn't want to
have fun with someone else especially
not with somebody else who loved me I
didn't want to I couldn't
or I didn't want to somewhere in there
you know because if I had
with that person you know if I stay
positive then then it's put it's really
putting yourself out there it's making
yourself real vulnerable you know
letting somebody see me have a good time
just hard for me you know just hard for
me to do there's something about it I
just I think I was afraid to let myself
be seen having a good time because if
you
fun if you know that I care about you
then that opens that opens up a lot of
risk that opens up a lot of risk and
it's easier to be negative that way ever
it shuts every
it shuts down all possibility it shuts
down all joy that could that could
happen but man just you know in
hindsight I wish I had lifted up more
than women than I that I you know I've
had relationships with you know the good
part of me does my heart definitely does
you knowing just be brave enough to you
know to let him see you have fun yet for
me I think people seeing me have a good
time or something maybe it was a sign of
weakness for me at times in my life or I
don't know and I'm not saying you know
I'm not having pity on myself or
anything I'm just trying to think about
why I didn't want why I would be
negative
and the saddest thing about it is when I
think back is I've got I've had the
blessing of being able to date some
really some women that were very
beautiful on the inside
first and foremost and I really shut
that down with a lot of my negativity
sometimes you know I just and uh and
that's not what I want to be about so I
think there's ways to figure it out man
I don't have it all figured out myself
so I can't really I can just relate to
kind of maybe somewhat of what you're
talking about but but yeah I don't know
exactly the solution man it's you know
one of the reasons that I know I
struggle in relationships you know and
it's okay I'm determined to you know to
get better and to get into a better
place with them and um and I do believe
that we can I do believe that and I
think we want it you know you sound like
a nice guy man you sound like somebody
that that I'd vote for it bro vote for
Pedro you know so just don't be too hard
on yourself man and we just we can learn
from our mistakes but we should we got
to figure out why we do it you know for
me a lot of it is I just uh if I let her
what if I'm in a relationship and a
woman sees me feeling good about myself
or sees me having fun or it's just scary
you know maybe it goes back to who knows
I don't know when I was young I just I
don't know I don't know man but keep
your head up and thanks for calling and
and helping me kind of think about it a
little bit you know I've been struggling
recently to really get in touch with any
of my feelings at all especially the
past six months so having this moment to
really to think about this even some
it's been nice for you it's been nice
for me so thank you bro
be good to yourself man I'll talk to you
soon all right let's take a call here
here we go yo CEO Dan Smith from
Minneapolis you wanted to call in for
comments questions concerns issues yep
thank you for calling Anthony
oh we're well this is an issue see at
the one hour and 22 minute mark of your
podcast and mr. Neal Brennan you've
decided out of all 30 teams of NBA you
compared your less than sex life to my
indiana pacers and that's when you made
it personal I can't I can't listen the
rest of podcast and to be honest I don't
know if I can even continue
ganghwa I respected thank you for thank
you for the call Anthony yeah if I think
about my sex life dude or my sexual
ability i'm the indiana pacers
and it's not sex life it's sex ability
man you know I'll keep shooting I'll
take some chances you know I'd do a few
more layups than I do dunks I steal um
you know I'll call a lot of timeouts and
I'm not like a real champion but but you
know but uh but I always you know I keep
playing and and I think yeah I think
that's where I am and I really do think
I'm the Indiana Pacers of when it comes
to sexual so thank you for the call man
and thank you for thinking about it all
right let's take another call here here
we go
hey Theo this is Brady from June 18
hunting in the great state of Ohio as a
big boy Buckeye State I just got a
question for you about hairstyles that
you are the king of hairstyle well um I
have a hairstyle I just for sure man you
know I got this hairstyle boy and I got
that splash baby go gang always had
short
I'm a senior in college and I'm really
debating on growing up my hair and
getting that juicy big board Paulette
that mullet huh you thinking about
mullet that mullet
Oh weird you know with that last
semester coming in you know in the
professional world I don't know if it's
a little bit too risque to have that big
wood mullet rolling around dude let me
tell you this about risque brother you
know what's risque to go through your
whole life looking like a dang head
chump you got to grow that splash baby
drop that back splash I'm talking about
that baby drape I'm talking about that
fricking magic carpet ride on the back
of your neck you ain't got the balls to
grow the falls brother you talk about
the professional world professional
playoffs do you write in your mind man
you're fresh out of college do you still
smell like LSD and liquor nobody's
giving you a decent job for a while
buddy bear okay so I think you need to
freaking get that honey drip off the
back let me tell you this man you walk
into an office with that mullet and
they'll love you they'll respect you
you're not just a man
you're a mascot you come in with that
mullet baby and people want to see it
you'll have ladies hanging off of it
where's the secretary we're having fun
we're uh and she you can't even find her
because every time you turn your head
she swings to the other side of you
because she's hanging off that curtain
you got to get that curtain baby that
certain curtain dog and some places it's
a mullet and in Europe okay which is a
lot of the world it is a hawk soccer
haircut you go up to Canada this is a
hockey haircut so it look but I'm saying
this if you want to live your whole life
never knowing what it feels like to be a
be stuck
then go on go get you a job dog but I'd
rather show up looking like the Lord's
boy
with that frickin waterfall
good luck out out in the world man
whatever you choose to do but you keep
that favor gang I'm going to tell you
this right now you got to know that
hiring can be a slow process especially
if everybody has the same haircut but
you see one person come in with that oh
you know straight up you got to drop
them trout lines on that neck baby you
got to come full you got to get that
lettuce baby you got to serve that
cabbage grow grow it out brother and get
a job man
you get a job dude doing whatever you
want wrestling body slamming the
neighbor making love dude once you get
that hair boy speaking of hair and
hiring hiring can be a slow process
Caffe alturas co o dillon Miska wits
needed to hire a director of coffee for
his organic coffee company but he was
having trouble finding qualified
applicants so he switched to zip
recruiter zip recruiter doesn't depend
on candidates finding you it finds them
for you it's technology identifies
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job so you
get qualified candidates fast Dillon
posted his job on zip recruiter and said
he was impressed by how quickly he had
great candidates apply he also used zip
recruiters candidate rating feature to
filter his applicants so he could focus
on the most relevant ones and that's how
Ilyn found his new director of coffee in
just a few days with results like that
it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
see why zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free
at our web address zip recruiter comm
slash tpw that's zip recruiter comm
slash tpw zip recruiter comm slash tpw
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire a
couple more calls man and I love these
and I'm and and and uh and I'm happy to
be here and I'm how you know and I'm
doing my best man I'm doing my best
you know sometimes I'm afraid I get
afraid to talk about stuff on here
sometimes I think I don't know what
happened I think I just got afraid
sometimes this year man I just got
afraid of everything oh but that's the
past man
and um and that's okay and everything is
gonna be okay
let's take another couple of calls man
here we go hey what's up Theo von this
is Luke from Tampa Florida what's up
Luke
thank you for hitting the hotline
brother and I'm real happy right now
uh I just asked out my crush no she's uh
crush at work you know we were friends I
was talking to her and I started to like
her and stuff and uh you know decided
today to ask her out and you know I just
came up to her and said you know do you
want to grab coffee or something
sometime a nice nice casual move and you
know she started to get weird and I just
said you know you can I know this is
weird you can say no if you want to and
she was just like I mean yeah we can get
get coffee as friends and that kind of
broke my heart a little bit
but now I you know now I know I can move
on and I don't have to catch feelings
for this girl anymore
and I did a good thing for my
self-esteem you know it hurts a little
bit but I know
long term this is good for me and this
was a this was a brave thing for me to
do I don't do stuff like that often so
I'm just real happy
so hey Thank You Man peace peace brother
thank you man that's awesome
hell yeah bro Luke out there getting it
in dude there's no getting rejected by a
woman fine lady you miss the bus if you
don't like being on the bus then bye
you missed it there that's brave man I
love it I love it because there ain't a
man out there who doesn't wish if they
could go back in time so many times that
they'd asked the girl out and that's not
you today it does wonders for your
self-esteem here and that inspired my
self-esteem man dude that's awesome yeah
do you and it what a great statement
that it hurts a little now but you know
now you're not going to have these
aimless wandering thoughts about her and
all of this and that you're gonna have
yeah you're it's clean in your book your
communication was real real clean man
that's awesome and that's communication
you had a feeling you communicated it
she communicated you recognized when she
felt a little uncomfortable which is
real nice you you didn't put this you
know you didn't put that hot iron on her
back man I commend you bro gang boy
that's what we do around here that's
what we we ask girls out we get rejected
Gang Gang boy self-esteem gang bra love
that dude thank you for calling man this
man that made me feel so good thank you
so much brother dang that's powerful
right there get out of your head get
into action he did it
did it let's take another call
hey Co I'm like I'm like you manic I got
that got that monkey on my back and I'm
just don't know what to do anymore thank
you for calling man let's hear more but
listen man I've been sober a handful of
times and I've had a few years under my
belt thing I was always going back to
the dark side you know and uh man I'm 42
years old and got these beautiful kids
and I got three of them and they're
amazing and I'm just starting to run out
of running out of gas man like I can't
hold up like I used to and I and the
drinking is just it scared me down I
feel ashamed to call on this line and in
Christ but I'm tired man it's wearing me
out I'm so tired and I don't feel
hopeless about getting back in the
program I think that's the main reason
I'm calling because I don't know how to
get that that help get that hope going
again and believe that that I can do
this one more time I just don't know how
to live sober scares the hell out of me
right these kids depend on me and that's
a lot of pressure and I'm I didn't grow
up like a lot of people I think I grew
up kind of like you and I don't really
know how to handle [ __ ] man
I'm just trying real hard but it's
getting harder and I'm starting to [ __ ]
things up and you know I was talking to
my buddy she's in my sponsor a bunch of
times but anyway he said you know he was
talking to me about the gambler about
how the gambler just keeps playing until
they lose that they're actually playing
to lose and I mean I and I think that
might be the case for me for some reason
like I don't know how to stop this thing
anyway man I don't know what I'm trying
to say to you and I don't even know why
I'm calling you about it you know like
it seems like the right thing to do
would be like light if you're asked to
the meeting you dummy and I and I hear
that but where I live man sometimes
meetings they don't they don't really
provide what you need not a lot of great
meetings around here but man I here's
the deal man I just want to stop this
[ __ ] man and I just want to be a good
dad I just want my kids I just want to
be something that my kids can look up to
and I have pride in and want to be like
but but that's not what they're seeing
right now
and now it's killing me man thanks for
calling man I appreciate it
I'm sorry you're having a tough time you
know as
you to call you know it shows that her
to me it shows that you care about
yourself yeah I can relate a lot man I
can relate a lot I think we are a lot
the same you know I just keep trying but
I was just not finding solution not
finding comfort man it gets tiring it
gets so tiring this the energy we spend
just to just just spinning our wheels
man
and the gambler there's a good reference
by your friend yeah sometimes just keep
playing just to lose you know so no when
I would smoke cigarettes I would smoke
them and I would be burned half when I'd
start smoking the next one before I even
finish the one I was on I put it out and
start smoking the next one because I
wasn't smoking to enjoy smoking I was
smoking just to burn myself down I
wanted to cook my heart like a damn
little chicken because I had control
over that yeah just play in the lose man
I don't care if I lose at leak but at
least I'll lose you know I'm in control
if I lose that's this thing that that's
this story that there is that's the
feeling you know watch me wreck my life
don't don't you care that was this thing
always inside of me watch me you know
watch me you know when it came to my
addiction and stuff or when it comes to
it that's the story that's inside of me
sometimes or that can be inside of me
watch me ruin everything because I'm in
control of that it's so hard to let go
of control that's the thing is so hard
to I mean you're doing it right there
when used to mean you're saying he tired
man
this brother
I'm tired I'm tired I'm tired of feeling
alone
I'm tired of not I'm tired also not even
being there for myself I mean that's the
loneliest bro when you don't even have
yourself because you've done set up so
many little goals for yourself and not
achieve them every time and time again
that you don't even trust yourself
in my experience cuz I mean I've had you
know I've had a recent experience with
this of just being sick of myself man I
got sick of myself this year you know
one of the best years of my life in some
circles and I didn't feel good you know
I didn't and it's not a and so what I
was doing was I wasn't doing anything to
take care of myself really I had to
start doing things different I had to
take action you know and I'm not telling
you what to do
but what has worked for me is taking
action and the meetings sometimes I go
to the meetings and the program works I
don't deny that 12-step that recovery
works and it's contrary action that's
the action I have to take a lot of times
you know when I don't want to go to the
meeting when I don't want to pray when I
don't want to ask for help
hard ask for help because we're you know
we you know we feel like we're the only
person that cares about us so and we've
always been the only person that cares
about us so to ask for help is like a
weakness you know that's what I found
for myself but but it's not man there's
so many gifts on the other side of that
there's so many gifts on in that book
it's not even about the meetings it's
about that book it's about the process
you know you could be in any meeting you
could be in the worst meeting and it's
about really it's it's about the meeting
that you have with yourself
meeting yourself in your heart and
saying hey I got to do things different
you know I really do want something
different for me I want to have some
self-esteem I want to feel good I want
to I want my kids to look at me and know
I'm gonna do whatever I say I'm gonna do
or are them to trust me and be reliable
all the things that I always hated
because I felt like they weren't there
for me are the things that my alcoholism
wants
to become you know drugs and
a side effect those are just I don't
know if I have addiction of those things
but I have addiction too but I have
addiction man I have a you know just not
feeling good about yourself
I can relate man I'm sorry that you're
dealing with it man I'm sorry I really
am brother man
and it's hard to go to those meetings
it's hard to say yeah I'm gonna do this
for myself it's hard to go back it's
hard to sit in a meeting that's not even
fun or good sometimes I'll go to
meetings it's not even good and I stay
it's just a test so then that's just a
test of patience but doing the work
doing the 12 steps man there is a
brighter side to it
and I'm sorry that you feel I'm assuming
you probably just feel so alone but uh
but that's just a feeling man that's not
true
the truth is there's probably a lot of
people that care about you and I'm one
of them and count me in you know when
you said that we're a lot of like man I
knew right then when you said that that
we are and I didn't know it in my ears
and in my brain I just knew it in my
heart there was nothing
there's nobody could you could cut a
million cables Brian you couldn't
disconnect that fact from me we are a
lot alike man and this isn't a self-pity
thing this ain't a pity party it's the
strongest thing to do to say I want to
have a bigger experience inside of my
heart you know it's
that's where the joy that's where the
circus is I want to be a billionaire in
my aortas brother that's what I want and
I believe you have to believe or I have
to believe that there is a way I have to
believe that but man I tell you that
that that those 12 steps do work and if
you're having trouble man maybe you know
ask your God or ask your ask God or ask
your higher power for some willingness
you know God just make me willing God
please today just help me have some
willingness to try something different
to try some contrary action I mean I do
stuff last night some friends invited me
to a hockey game first hockey game I had
a chance to go to I didn't want to go
because something inside of me wants to
isolate it wants to be by myself it
wants to you know let my feelings of you
know less than they wants to let him out
like squirrels and let him run around
all over my body but I say yes I will go
yes I will be there at this time and I
went and dude I had a great time I had a
great time and that's contrary action I
learned that from you know the program
because I
contrary action a lot of times I want to
do it my way because that's the way I
always did it I felt like I did things
my way nobody cared I'm doing it my way
and that works for a long time that
worked for me for a long time until it
didn't work anymore you know until it
just didn't work anymore and that's okay
I recognize that that pattern doesn't
work and I need to develop a new pattern
but I believe you I believe in you man
I believe that you can do it and you got
three beautiful kids dude that's awesome
man you got those gifts man you got
gifts you got gifts flying out of your
dick brother honestly you know I hate to
be profane like that but I wasn't gonna
say that and then I just said it but but
man you got a big heart bro and
you can do it man if you really want it
you can do it I believe in you man and I
and I bet you believe in you too but
we're strong willed bro when we want to
do something we can do it and uh I love
you bro gang man thank you for thank you
for the call all right let's take a man
sorry I was just I was man it takes
power scary it's you know it takes power
it's brave bro that's brave man we're
brave we be in focus so just today gang
let's take a call hey Co this is Ryan
from Idaho just calling I know you get a
lot of problems in whatever but I just
want to call and thank you from the
bottom of my heart for your podcast it's
got me through some really rough days
trying to clean up and and get my life
back together I'm now celebrating five
months of sobriety today and you know
your podcast has been a really awesome
anchor for me throughout the day so I
don't burn down my place of employment
you know but yeah man I just wanna say I
appreciate you love you and keep doing
what you're doing man Jane Jane gang
brah Thank You Man thank you for the
call thank you for the warm words you
did that you know it's nice you too to
say thank you to me and uh you know I
love where your hearts at with that but
you did that you know you chose to do
something for yourself and you did it
you know that's your father wants a
sobriety that's the thing about that
program man
it is not a they don't have this mean
they don't have these people this it is
a program it is you it's you against the
devil's inside of you and you chose to
challenge a man in five months dude
that's amazing
you know in the past year I lost three
friends who overdosed and and it's scary
out there you know I don't like to think
I don't like to I notice is you know
this episode has gotten kind of real and
a lot of them have been my life's it's
been [ __ ] it's been hard for me to be
funny this year which is crazy because
it's been the year of you know most
comedy success for me am I am I work but
on my human side it's you know the
battle is different and man thank you so
much for calling the saying that you got
five months do that makes me feel so
good bro
it makes me feel so good to know just to
hear that when you share that dude
that's you sharin hope let's hope let's
hope you're sharing man we're getting
this bro
everybody everybody dude we're getting
shot down by our crushes bro you feel me
and that's how we do it we get rejected
boy
[Music]
nobody gets rejected like us rejection
gang bruh
that's who we are man y'all got me fired
up I love this dude thank you guys so
thanks for being a part of my day today
let's take this one last call um let's
take this one last call here oh this is
Tim Dimmick from San Antonio Texas
what's up timmy thank you for calling
baby I've been going to recovery for the
past nine months trying to get my life
better the last three years amen brother
which you got for us Tim it really got
serious about it the last five months so
I went to my church moved away from my
town in Austin Texas San Antonio Texas
when with my church got connected the
we started serving in my church like my
higher power shirt for me you got
connected you started doing service I
like it bro and what it happened was
this this Christmas they're giving out
five big gifts now the cool thing about
the big gift is that our church fashion
on a bucket at KFC bucket Dan your
church pass around a real KFC bucket
brother the Angels have wings over there
Brian and breasts and thighs boy look at
the Nuggets on them and Helios onward
Papa and we all put money in the bucket
and then it passed around again says he
got bills take out of the bucket the
money left over from fire services in
Community Bible Church with 75 grand and
me going through my struggles and being
service to the church but him what you
want a walkie-talkie baby but I love it
bro that's communication dude I'll
communicate with it damn slingshot brah
whisper into the frickin into that
little into that little holster own a
slingshot and fire that secret across
the universe gang onward they had
noticed that my vehicle wasn't the best
shape and it was 99 Ford Ranger I got
into a wreck in April and broke the back
windshield with my face long story but
you drive like a professional wrestler
in the eighties boy yes gangsta son
homework short the church said I was the
first qualified participant to receive a
brand-new 2011 Ford f-150
god bless me all I can say is that if
this helps one person come to recovery
then it'll all be it'll all be worth it
I did have a huge blessing to my life
and I just wanted to share that with
your audience and you as well man gangs
you know said you know what I'm [ __ ]
all right gang bro that's awesome man
thanks for sharing that dude wow you got
to
truck there that's amazing bro there
that's so great well you can hear the
gratitude right there you can hear the
gratitude in that man thank you for
sharing bro man I just to hear somebody
be so grateful bro that's awesome man
just reminds me of the things I'm
grateful for dude and how I just man I
lost that this year I lost feeling a
gratitude
you know I wake up in a world man I wake
up in a world I'm a human being that's
amazing man I'm a spirit that gets to be
in this thing that's a gift man you know
what I'm not trying to sound preachy or
anything and I didn't make this episode
to be all about you know people that are
struggling with recovery or anything
like that I mean held a one lady is
struggling with farts in her bed but you
know I was listening to the calls today
and man uh it just hit me in the heart
man you know there's a special group of
people that are that are part of this
podcast man and uh I think part of me
man I feel I don't feel bad I just I
forgot that this year you know I did I
struggled this year feeling gratitude so
much and I had so much to be grateful
for and one of the things that I didn't
realize how grateful I was was just uh
for the dish that there's an amazing
group of people that that tune in here
and then and when I listen to the voice
mails I feel like just a listener you
know I'm just somebody just it's like
we're just like it's like an echo
chamber we're just throwing it back and
forth
oh but yeah I really struggle with
gratitude this year and it was so it was
hard because all I wanted to be was
grateful and I couldn't feel it I could
say it but I just couldn't feel it man
that's okay you know I learned it and I
figure it out and and it's getting
better and uh but man that's beautiful
do you got a truck man and you need to
get places and you trying to do
something and you know action creates
action this guy showed up who his
program whatever it is you know he
showed up he showed up he showed up and
next thing you know he got wheels under
him now he's got a way to show up easily
and that's dude that's awesome that's
awesome man
anything you want that was the song
about Bishop gun you can have anything
you want and it does take work man but
never in my life have I worked for
something and not had it equal something
I don't know if any of us have you have
you ever worked real hard for something
and not gotten it not gotten something
not gotten something out of it
you always get a gift on the inside or
on the outside you know God
150 in EUR in your driveway or in your
driveway brother in your heart and uh
yeah I don't know what I'm talking about
rambling but man I'm just everything's
gonna be okay it is baby it is I mean
those two men are stuck in that Blizzard
dude with that dog
jeepers so you know and I mean if
anything prey for that animal and I
think it didn't one all of that it
didn't one all of that but we got this
we're making it man thank you to
everybody that called in think yet
everybody that paid attention thank you
to everybody that's coming out to one of
these future shows thank you for being
my friend through this you know I don't
know what I'm doing when I started this
podcast and I don't know what I'm doing
ever but you know I'm just grateful I
can whew
the other side of like the tough stuff
I've been feeling this year and uh and
I'm just grateful man I just got scared
this year I had so much ego I couldn't
just everything inside of me just all
this fear just flared up and I just had
a tough time and I know some of you
might not notice something you don't
care that's fine that's fine they're
saying about I guess it's just about
it's about me right now but man I just
just when I was listening to those calls
today was the best part of my day you
know you know why cuz I just didn't feel
alone man I didn't feel alone and that's
it man
we can get our dreams I was gonna play
making it but that's too slow man we
live we lift her than it we lift her
than that we didn't do we got a crush
ask her out even if she's married go ask
her out she tells you to go [ __ ]
yourself you say [ __ ] yeah just got
rejected checkmate
cuz that's what we do we do what we want
bro that's safe for others but we do
what we want and we get rejected and we
take our chances and this brave man is
contrary action everything and your body
says no when you say yes and you move
your feet we move our feet and our brain
will follow you can't think your way in
a positive action which you can act your
way in a positive thinking that's the
oldest say we can do it
I'm getting preachy we can do it man you
guys be good to yourselves man you can
have anything you want I believe that
and thank you for uh for being a great
part of my day gang
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh
[Music]
to assist with another man's ocean
wrote to a papery on the team
[Music]
you guys be good to your sales man you
deserve it okay